a growing number of Democrats including
some presidential candidates say that
Congress must start an impeachment
investigation of President Trump they
believe that Robert mother wants them to
do it
the former special counsel spoke about
the Russia investigation for the first
time yesterday Muller emphasized his
final report did not clear the president
of suspected criminality Paula Reid is
at the White House Paula how did the
Muellers and remarks change the
narrative here Anthony in just 10
minutes Muller undercut months of Trump
administration's spin claiming that the
special counsel had cleared the
President on obstruction of justice if
we had had confidence that the president
clearly did not commit a crime we would
have said so Robert Muller used his
first public statement in two years to
make it clear he did not exonerate the
president of obstruction of justice we
did not however make a determination as
to whether the President did commit a
crime president Trump has previously
claimed the report did exonerate him
after his attorney general william Barr
cleared the president of obstruction but
yesterday President Trump appeared to
take a more nuanced approach tweeting
there was insufficient evidence and
therefore in our country a person is
innocent Muller implied he could not
charge the president because of a
Justice Department policy that a sitting
president cannot be indicted it would be
unfair to potentially accuse somebody of
a crime when there can be no court
resolution of the actual charge he then
suggested it was up to Congress to
pursue the evidence he's uncovered the
Constitution requires a process other
than the criminal justice system to
formally accuse a sitting president of
wrongdoing many Democrats including a
number of candidates for president took
Muller statement as a call to impeach
this is as close to an impeachment
referral as you could get under the
circumstances he's laying this at the
lap of Congress to go forward I would
suggest that he told us enough to
interpret what he said as a referral for
impeachment proceedings he is demanding
that we do this now or forever lose the
opportunity to act
Muller said he hopes this will be his
last public comment on the matter but
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi may have
other plans
yes I think it would be useful for him
to testify before Congress Mahler also
wanted to make sure that despite all the
controversy swirling around the
president that the public didn't lose
sight of the fact that his investigation
uncovered extensive efforts by Russia to
interfere in the 2016 election he
charged dozens of Russian nationals
though it's unlikely any of them will
ever see the inside of a US courtroom
Tony all right Paula thank you very much